the united nations has sounded the alarm
bell on the issue of world refugees it
says the number has exceeded 100 million
for the first time on record in the
words of the unhcr commissioner felipe
granty the figure is sobering and
alarming in equal measure
since the war broke out in february the
rate of refugees and displaced people
has been accelerated as early as march
2.5 million ukrainians left their
country
the u.n is expecting the figure to
exceed 8 million by the end of this year
grandi says the new crisis should not
distract us from the old ones
i think an important message and you
mentioned it joseph is that
there is not just ukraine that we should
not forget all the rest
first of all because ukraine has an
impact on many other
fragile situations making it more fraud
making them more fragile food security
energy crisis
price increases instability
and then this
in turn can cause more displacement
by the end of last june the number of
forcibly displaced people worldwide rose
toward 90 million it's the result of
violence in ethiopia for a faso myanmar
nigeria afghanistan the democratic
republic of the congo and other
countries
as the number of refugees across the
world increases relief agencies become
less capable of handling the situation
the u.n humanitarian office ocha warns
nearly 18 million people are going to
face severe food shortages in the next
three months across the african sahara
region
the office's appeal for 3.8 billion
dollars for relief has generated less
than 12 percent of that amount so far
in palestine
one of the oldest refugee crises goes on
with no end in sight
other refugee crises have been around
for decades as well
governments and international
organizations will now need to think of
a new way to address this unending
problem muhammad al jazeera